you know this doesn't have to be perfect
you know
that's what i'm thinking about right now
this doesn't have to be perfect and
oh isn't that a nice thing to say
this doesn't have to be perfect i gotta
remember that
what it is what it ain't does the baby
need a spank that used to be a little
limerick
and a limerick is a basically a
little irish poem or something little
irish
it's basically the irish you can't
really a lot of time you can't even
understand them
so people were so happy when they
finally heard
something out of the iris that they
could understood they gave it a dang
name limerick
and uh
anyway that's old irish limerick what it
is what it ain't
does the baby need a spanx have me a
couple advil right now
ah with that liquid death i don't know
if you've ever had advil or not
but i have them you know i advil to
everything i do man hell i wish i made a
damn suppository
you know when i was young there was a
thing called um
vegipness and i hate to get crude and be
a naughty boy out here early but when i
was young they had a thing called
vegipen
and that was traveling through the south
right around the time that um
you know uh what was it called uh
jenkum and jenkum was an
old deal where they would put
you know man this is sorry it's a little
profane but they put uh
animal fesses and stuff like that booty
you know animal you know booty work into
a jug and they would let it
roast in the sun and they would put a
balloon on the top of the bottle
and human fesses as well and urine
or urine they call it up in michigan up
in the uh
up in the u.p but they would uh
put that in a jug like a two liter
bottle get you a seven up d
or a you know uh
diet dr pepper big daddy you know one of
them two liters
and um and they would you put a balloon
on top and they would let the
the the waste in there fester
and the gas from it put it in the yard
somebody's yard could be your yard it
was embarrassing to put it in your yard
so people put it in somebody's yard you
know maybe an old person who's not gonna
see it
a lot of time you do that kind of [ __ ]
you know if you got something messed up
you put it in old person yard for a
little while
let people think they're doing it you
know or something but
um and the sun would hit it it would
fill the balloon with gas
and that gas was made out of uh fester
and urine
and uh fesses and then you would take
that gas you know
and you would huff it and people would
hit that jenkins it was called
uh what was it nickname let me see
nicknames
for jinkum
um
let me see right here jenkum uh
okay jenkum a highly hallucinogenic drug
which results from huffing the fumes
they get naughty out here on the
interwebs baby
highly hallucinogenic that means top of
the line we're talking big daddy
we're talking really if you this is like
damn
setting your dick on a frog's back you
know for an hour kind of thing
highly hallucinogenic drug which results
from huffing the fumes of your own
fermented
fecal matter users claim
users claim it gives an incredible rush
that's what they call it right there
jenkum right there and here's an
alternate title getting a bottle
uh uh and taping a balloon
to the top and letting your
piece and turd ferment
man we getting naughty out here then
removing the
[ __ ] man this stuff here's alternate
definition getting a
sorry man getting a bottle and taping a
balloon to the top
letting your pee pee pee
and turd ferment for a few days and i'm
sorry it's getting a little graphic
for a few days weeks even then removing
the balloon
and inhaling that gas baby getting that
[Music]
getting that huff baby getting that puff
puff you know
and they say it creates an awesome high
it's an african drug
in africa they cannot afford drugs it
says so they invented
jenkum whoo whoo
uh and that's that chardonnay bro you
know what i'm saying you wait a couple
of weeks
i mean you wait a couple of weeks that's
that chardonnay bro heavy on the shark
um anyway what i'm saying is i had some
advil
and i have them a lot and if they made a
suppository i would have one
you know i put a damn thousand
milligrams i'd hide it in that back jaw
early in the morning man so
if anybody's out there doing jenkins or
doing whatever man i hope that you're
not riding it too hard today
a hallucinogenic drug made out of the
collected fumes of fermented fessies and
urine
uh leave it in the sun for a few days
that huff mcgruff
that pooter juice is a nickname
and another nickname for some reason is
terrence and phillip so i don't know
what that means maybe that could have
been some gay men that was doing
being wild outdoors so i'm not sure
not sure about that not sure what god
wants on that um
welcome to the episode let's get into it
come on
[Music]
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
[Music]
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
grown come on
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves
[Music]
[Music]
in my bones but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on wire shine that light on
me
i'll spit and tell you my story
and there you go that's shine by bishop
gun
and that's that ordinary connection
piece right there for us
that's that mild
tightrope between souls people have
heard it before they hear it again
and that is familiarity
you know i like i like i like uh
familiarity
familiarity it sounds
familiarity it sound like a drug for a
baby
you know this baby he
honestly man we caught him smoking
you know we caught him looking at other
babies tits you know we caught so we had
to put him on a couple doses of uh
familiarity and he's hopefully he'll be
better we don't know
you know his brother ended up in jail so
who knows but
familiarity i like familiarity
i like being in places that make me feel
comfortable i like
you know sometimes i i remember when i
was young i would get in the christmas
boxes you know
um and if somebody got a gift second
they got it out i'd be in that bastard
somebody got a little toaster you know
somebody get a little toaster i'd be in
that [ __ ]
you know somebody got a little uh
capital gray skull or something set
toy box thing i'd be uh you'd see me in
there
like a cat
and i like that i just liked uh being in
a tight little
closed space kind of i'm that womb
hunter you know
i'm always looking to skirt back
i'm always looking for an umbilical cord
just hanging anywhere i'll climb right
back up that bad i don't care
who's running womb baby
i don't care how far zan i gotta climb
baby oh
i will swing into that bastard
i like that attic i always like that
closed space
i like that tightness that that little
domicile they call it
i like being in a little capsule
hell i'll probably enjoy being dead
honestly
you know i miss you guys but i will be i
will enjoy it because i want in that
coffin baby i'm getting that [ __ ] tight
sometimes you see people with these big
bodies you know sometimes you'll see a
brother or something be buried with that
being that big body
ah not me i want that coffin i want that
thing be damn a foot and a half wide
baby 18 inches you know
i want that thing right at six feet man
and honestly man they could bend my legs
a little make that [ __ ] at five and a
half feet
i want that tight i want that easy i
want something that could
you know you could mistake it for a damn
uh
bunch of roses on you know delivered by
somebody by a company
like damn is that somebody burying a box
of roses
that's what i want that because i like
the tightness i like that close knit
i like that and i don't wear too big of
a shirt i don't wear too much of a large
shirt either
you'll see me insi you know in a
semi-large
really which i wish there was a size
that they made
i like that lean large you know
man it was something i was going to tell
you just forgot about oh
so for a while man i was doing drugs and
i used to live with this man named kenny
and they called him two cat kenny
because he had he had two cats and uh
and i would do drugs and [ __ ] and one
night he came and knocked on my door i'd
i was uh living in his apartment he
lived there and i moved in
and so i had my own room and i was
excited man i had me a little couch in
there
you know it was a big room it was kind
of i could be in my bed or be in my
couch [ __ ] i'm all over
you know i had that kind of atmosphere
in there
and got me a little ice chest in the
corner i put a couple little
little beverages in that bastard you
know
i put me a couple waters couple [ __ ]
uh maybe uh
you know maybe diet sprites in that
[ __ ] you know live it up i was
doing it all and anyway so sometimes one
night kenny come in my room the first
time he did it he came in he said hey
come out here and he would get high out
there in the living room i think or he
was on something
and if you've ever had a roommate that's
on something when they knock on your
door in your room door you know it's
anything could be behind anything could
be going on
they could need help they could be
bleeding they could be missing
you know you some with some roommates
that throw on some drugs they'll knock
and go missing by the time you get to
the damn door like damn
this some real there's some real [ __ ]
right here this person they really
they just can't even find themselves
right now so anyway
i came in the door and kenny been out in
the living room he stacked a bunch of
boxes out there big pyramid of boxes
you know that egyptian shape and he he
he put that thing we had high ceiling
living room
high ceiling living room and he'd
invited this lady over from next door
this lady martha was her name and she
always got stoned and she look
i mean she was she wasn't [ __ ] honestly
and i hate to say that and i hope she's
better now but at the time she was just
she wasn't really [ __ ] man you know
she wasn't she just what man i just i
shouldn't say that she was [ __ ] she was
uh she was awesome
she was awesome but i didn't see that
side of her
and uh and anyway so him and martha's
out there huffing uh
doing something i don't think he's
huffing paint doing a keyboard clean or
some kind of [ __ ]
but they got the cats on these boxes on
these pyramidal boxes
and kenny's like man you'll never guess
what's in the top man
and he had his little cat up there
buckeye was his name
you know because he had a real uh he had
like kind of
kind of gold hair around his [ __ ]
honestly butthole b-hole
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry b-hole
in case any moms are driving their kids
to school right now bought a b-hole
and they call him buckeye and uh
and he had no tail on him i mean his
tail had been trimmed all the way
straight to the spine so you saw just
you was getting full hole on that cat
you know you was getting ultimate hole
you know that's u-hole because there's
b-hole and there's u-hole bro and that's
when you just
god you just hope for better you know
but anyway so what happened was
uh buckeye had gotten somehow into the
box on the top of the damn thing bro
top of that pyramid and they're out
there on that keyboard cleaner you know
and they've been huffing that and doing
a little
you know doing a little bit of weed or
uppers or downers or
something side splitters i don't know
what they were on but they were bent out
and i knew when i opened that door he's
sitting there martha's there
and they're just [ __ ] watching that
cat up there in that big box in that
pyramid
man i knew i had to get out of there
that's what i knew at that time baby
amen and i want to let you guys know
about the tour
actually pre-sale tickets are available
now
through thursday may 6th at 10 p.m
now through then go to theovonne.com
tour t-o-u-r and enter the code
weekend um and that's before they'll be
available to everyone else
they're available to the listeners of
this podcast and thank you for being a
part of my life
and that's the code and some of the
cities we're coming to saint louis
uh cincinnati these are in september
these dates are a little ways out
st louis cincinnati charlotte
uh carolina uh
durham north carolina sorry at the
carolina theater
uh the tivoli theater over there in
chattanooga
tennessee and i'll be happy to be over
there my mother used to live over there
with a man
knoxville tennessee at the tennessee
theater
wilmington delaware at the grand opera
house and wilkes bar
at the fm kirby center
so that'll be the first leg of that tour
and uh oh also minneapolis
charleston richmond virginia
baltimore maryland albany new york
at the egg buffalo new york
in columbus ohio at the davidson theater
so a lot of great places man i'm excited
to do that and that tour will figure out
the name
um but that'll be coming to you and so
be ready for
it what else is happening man what's
going on in your lives
i want to know some of that and and
we'll figure some of that out i'm trying
to think of what's going on with me
oh i want to update you on the ketamine
uh therapy
so if people know or don't know some of
you know i got the ketamine therapy
going and i have
uh two more treatments
and man um you know and i've been going
to my regular meetings and stuff like
that my regular recovery stuff at the
same time and
uh but man it's
i'd never done anything like this
so you're in there and they give you an
iv and they put the
drugs in in the end of the thing and you
have the therapist there
and at first you're in the room
and then dude it got
it got dicey man i mean i'm talking las
vegas dicey i'm not talking damn reno
i'm talking vegas dicey you know i'm
talking [ __ ]
out back at the venetian a couple
brothers gambling you know saying i'm
saying it got
dicey i'm talking about the weights the
the the cook staff out there gambling in
the alley
it's just like it's almost like somebody
takes
part of you your soul i'll say
and uh you ever been to a dry cleaners
and you go in there and you look and you
see they got all the equipment
and you're like oh man they got a lot of
equipment in here
um and they got the thing when they
press the button it kind of like
and other people's shirts go by and
you're like damn that guy's got nice
[ __ ]
man and you sometimes you bet you'll if
it's a smallest town you'll see somebody
something go by you're like oh man
i bet that's miss irma's you know oh
that looks like randall's [ __ ] you know
it
looked like randall's little boots you
know oh damn that's his stuff too he's
about to come out the closet you know
i'm saying you start to get that vibe
when things go by but
it's like somebody took your head your
spirit and put it onto that
and press the maximum button they could
and let that
[ __ ] go
like i remember at one point yelling out
that i was a cryptocurrency
so that's how you start to feel man
things get
you go into the matrix
you go into the i mean you're in the
you're on the mayflower in the matrix
eating flour uh performing tricks you're
doing there's a lot
a lot of levels going on man it feels
like elon musk just climbs straight in
the ass and comes out of your brain like
it's a lot of
um
it's like this part and i know this
sounds crazy it's not like being a high
on weed it's not like being high on
cocaine it's
it wasn't like the dmt uh it was a
little bit like the dmt
but not visual it's like this
i remember at one point all the
furniture in the world
moved across the globe into
into one little half bathroom
on the edge of zaire that's what i just
remember that happened
in a matter of a couple seconds it's
like you're on a and then at certain
moments it's like you're on a
uh it's like you're in a wheelchair but
also
you're like on a r what's it called ross
solar
uh roller coaster
you're on a roller coaster but you're
also in a wheelchair at the same time
like it's
i mean you're i don't know man
but some interesting stuff happened i
got to see myself as a child i got to
uh i got to
i got to just you kind of
i felt like i kind of had just
had to start growing up
if that makes any sense i felt like it
kind of made me realize some things i
just have to grow up a little
[ __ ] you know i got to at least hit 10
emotionally or 11.
so so anyway i think it's really
interesting though
like i'm monitoring how i feel if my
mood feels better
i'm hoping to be able to quit
antidepressants with the help of a
doctor
um and uh
and so that's some of the things that
i'm hopeful for
in it uh but i wanted to update you guys
on it
um for me it's a lot about just feeling
okay like am i okay
am i okay so that's the kind of a lot of
thing that i talk about when
i'm in there under the influence
because there's some moments where i'm
like is this really helpful or am i just
doing drugs in a strip mall somewhere
you know what i'm saying like am i just
doing drugs by this damn five guys you
know i'm saying what's really going on
here
um and that's the crazy part the place i
go you're wall-to-wall with a damn five
guys dude and four of those guys smell
like [ __ ] burgers bro i'll tell you
that i don't know who the fifth dude is
but
four of those mf smell like burgers bro
so it's hard cause you're getting you
know they got you on the grill and
you know mentally on the spiritual grill
in there in the same time
if you almost put your ear up i swear to
god i could hear somebody
finishing off a double in there and
god that really will that'll make you
want to get well right there when
there's a burger in the next room
it's kind of crazy the power of that um
uh so i wanna also dude i wanna say this
i'm upstairs
um i wanna wanna say this
a lot dude that's one thing i wish about
my my house now i have a
i have a house and it's crazy to say
that i'm almost getting shame to say it
in a sad way i know that's weird to say
but sometimes i feel like i'm
embarrassed i guess
um to like have stuff i don't know
i think i just relate so much with not
having anything
and with being um
i don't know about poor but with that
struggle with that like
chip on my shoulder that it's scary to
now
be in a place where i feel like
you know i have a dang living room
you know where you can live
you know like
like if my house burns down like they're
gonna call me
like that's crazy like i'm used to kind
of being in the place where if the place
burns down you call
somebody else who's gonna be pissed off
they're gonna be pissed unless they
burned it which happened to us once over
there
off of lee road did the dude burn the
damn place down to get money
and i mean let us know by letter first
of all
idiot and second of all call us bro if
you're gonna burn the place down
call us hey feel that heat
so don't let us know about damn letter
where you can get busted and
where we don't even get the letter
laughter you know
so just that kind of [ __ ] man but
anyway so i knew what i was talking
about
uh yeah that's it oh my mom came to
visit
i'll tell you about that in just a
second i wanna let you know first though
we gotta we gotta do the ads and i gotta
let you know about the podcast and
things that are going on so
i appreciate your support i appreciate
your support man
mint mobile you gotta get your mobile
well
and some people you try to call them you
can't call them
if you want some people if you want to
start a fire at their house you got to
mail them you know where you got a damn
right you know
write something on a damn animal's back
and slap it on the ass and send it in
that direction
or you got to hire a paul revere but not
with mint mobile
mint mobile offers premium wireless
service
starting at just 15 bucks a month that's
what they do
what's the catch well by cutting out
retail stores
there's no crazy overhead costs that get
passed down to you
in the form of mystery fees instead mint
just passes on sweet savings
direct to you now you're going to think
it can't be 15 bucks a month and i'm
going to tell you that it is and that it
works
for people looking for extra savings
premium wireless 15 bucks a month
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan
if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied that's full percent that's top
that's satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven-day money-back guarantee
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mint
mobile.com theo that's
m-i-n-t-m-o-b-i-l-e
dot com slash t-h-e-o cut your wireless
bill
to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com
theo and where would we we where would
we be
without them dick uppers baby you know
it and i hate to say it but you know
what i'm talking about
them rod launchers baby them def
leppard lifters baby you know that blue
chew
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and silas
but in chewable form finally
chew your way to a decent dick
you can do it blue chew is an
online prescription service i have
gotten online
i have gotten them delivered and i have
chewed my way
to sexual confidence brother no doctors
visits no awkward conversions
no waiting in line at pharmacy ships
right to your door in discreet package
and people won't know
they ship it in a little thing like oh a
little pinata full of dick getters
you know little uh oh look they put
oh oh he bought some roller skates
and next thing you know you rolling up
to a date
with that beef diving board fam let's
play ball
blue shoes tablets are made in the usa
that's right hacksaw jim duggan style
baby
ship direct to you special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code theo at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
you know what's the saddest part i
forgot to use the damn promo code
i kid you not baby bear i'm upstairs
i kid you not that's bluechu.com promo
code t-h-e-o
to receive your first month free and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring
this podcast they work and look you
don't have to have a hole and get you a
little half get you a little nibble
you're on a date it's going okay nibble
off a little chunk that's how i
am i save money like that baby
and then keep your little ziplock in the
car but you know
a couple of half you know a couple of
half out dps or making it a dust
that's what i do too make that you know
put in a little
you know put some water in a spoon you
know i'm joking
that's a joke just so you don't want
anybody
cooking themselves down uh
what else man let's hear uh we got a
call that came in right here
we got some single moms you know it's
mother's day week
um i spent some time my mother was in
town
and uh and you know we had a nice time
man we had a nice time i'll get to that
in just a second first i want to get to
this fellas call here we go
um big fan of shows calling in rather
not
give my name for personal reasons but uh
okay
and that's probably uh child support i'm
guessing
yes sir go ahead i've been going through
a big
transitional time in my life with uh
therapy and stuff like that and
just listen to a new episode and you
talked about doing the
ketamine therapy and i actually just
finished my six sessions
of uh doing that and it was just
really nice to hear that someone i look
up to you know has
taken the same route of trying to get
some self-help like i am because i kind
of felt alone in it like no one else
really
understood what it was or anything and i
kind of took a diet and went for it and
uh
i got to tell you i was cracking up when
you were talking about the
the crying in the first session because
when i did my first session i felt like
there was a
[ __ ] tear tractor beam in front of my
face pulling
pulling everything i had out of me and
yep that tear tractor baby
and somebody's using a skill saw nearby
if you can hear a sound
onward it felt good but like you said
it's real emotionally draining but um
yeah i just wanted to say stick with it
man because i finished mine and it's
helped me be much more emotionally
expressive to
people around me and really strengthen
my relationships with people that uh i
have in my life and
also uh thanks for doing the show he's
got me through some
hard times i think that you know you
you put a smile on people's face a lot
more than you might think you do and
help them get through some rough times
just from you
talking and shooting the [ __ ] on your
show so thanks again man
gang gay gang brother thank you i
appreciate you know
the you know that's sweetie to say that
man thank you thank you for calling
uh yeah you know i was scared to do it i
was scared to talk about it
honestly um you know but also i would
like you
you know i just i want to be proactive
in trying to feel good
you know um and yeah that for and i'll
try anything
you know here's the thing i've tried
like street drugs
so to try something that's you know
that at least even if it's a street drug
it's being used in a positive way
or you know a way that's like
directionally
decent then that
shoot i'm you know i'm a sucker for that
i guess then
oh but yeah thanks man um
i'm glad i did it you know i'm glad i'm
doing it and uh
and it's interesting it's really
interesting i'm curious to see
kind of some of the effects some of the
long-term effects if there are any
um i'm just curious and
and you know i wonder if years from now
there will be cures for some of this
stuff
uh sometimes i still think it's just a
spiritual
malady that i have and that it has
nothing to do with
anything else but you know i want to
exhaust every
option so that's what i'm gonna do um
or i don't know if that's what i'm gonna
do but we'll see what i'm gonna do i
don't even know what i'm gonna do
damn but thanks man i'm glad you checked
it out man
thanks for the good words you know i had
an epiphany just or just an idea i don't
know what it was
i mean epiphany's just a damn idea and a
skirt you know that bruh
it's just an idea that showed up to
happy hour
with lipstick and a condom in its sock
you know what i'm saying epiphany
oh you know epiphany she likes to get it
right you feel me
so um
what else man let's take another call
that came in here
here we go
what's up theo it's aaron from oklahoma
city
what's up aaron oklahoma city man y'all
did that bombing bro
and uh and what else man
um oh yeah kevin durant also baby let's
go
gang i know you say you used to be a bus
boy i'm a bus boy as well i was
wondering if you had
any crazy bus boy stories like weird
conversations you overheard or something
damn was your daddy a typewriter dog
because you definitely
you know you got that kind of that
stenographer's vibe
man uh
any good busboy stories well alfonso
rivieros came in one time when i was bus
boying
kevin costner came in and he ate three
muffins i remember that he liked them
yeah he did like them uh what else
happened um
oh dude so my boy dennis we used to do
drugs and
the first time we ever did some cocaine
he took me over to somebody's house
and the guy only had one eye you know he
had that buck shot baby or whatever
you know he had that uh
you know he honestly just kind of his
face was kind of [ __ ]
brave it's like hey i'll do it with one
you know check ball you know what i'm
saying bro
and he just checked that other one at
the door baby his face said look fam
we going one we going one rock
so i respect that man the guy i don't
remember his name
but i walk in and the guy's coming up
from doing a line of cocaine there's a
thing of fresh oranges on the table
um and he looked up at me and only had
one eye and i thought i was already
[ __ ] up
i thought that the guy had kind of
sucked so hard with his nostril he took
one of his eyes back into his head
you know and at that point i'm thinking
he's just seeing snot you know
seeing the inside of his capabilities
but um
but what else man yeah that i mean some
other stuff happened i remember i found
an
abbey road tape and it's a cassette tape
and some people don't believe in them
but i believed in them
and i found that on the side of the road
and i used that for a while
listen to that album that was my
introduction to the beatles really
and i would time it just perfectly when
i left work when i put on that one
song uh
uh imagine i don't know what it is
but it was a good song man i would time
it just perfectly when i left work
i had me a little dural or a little
winston
and i would cut that [ __ ] on with a
lighter
and i fire up that 1984 ford escort lazy
upstairs
and i would drive that thing
right to home and i would get to my
mom's place this is out in tucson
arizona out there
and it was a lot of like a lot of
mexican scare a lot of scare there's a
lot of just mexicans fighting at school
they called it school but it was
basically mexican people fighting
and then there was some but like
occasionally someone would
read a book report but um
and uh and i would just get to my
mother's house and that last
touch of that that last huff of that
doral baby
and i really love that i missed that
time so
but thank you for uh reminding me aaron
of that and good luck out there in okc
man and um
if anybody uh is in
oklahoma city and they see a busboy see
if he's aaron that could be him
um we got a call that came in here
this fella right here beautiful fella
here we go it could be beautiful this is
just audio
hey what's going on theo this is matt
i'm out here in washington
state i just was curious what's up
washington state
out there tacoma man and you guys
unfortunately gonzaga went out
and people don't know they're based out
of spokane
and i spent some time up and washed up
in uh
near snoke wyoming out there and i had
some girl
uh met a girl out there i made love to
out there one time
she worked in
i don't want to say arts and crafts
surplus but yarn sales i remember she
had a
little subaru hatchback full of yarn
multi-colored yarn baby
beautiful little lady let's hear more
brother onward
if you had any advice for me or if maybe
any listeners had some advice for me
i've been in the military for about five
years now and i joined right out of high
school
i'm about to get out i'm coming up here
in august
i'm just seeing if uh anybody had any
advice you know it's pretty
nerve-wracking i didn't i haven't known
anything else my whole life i've only
been in the military so
working on getting jobs lined up house
for me my wife what not like that so
if you or any of the listeners had any
advice for me i appreciate it
uh you know gang gang
thanks maddie and yeah you know that's a
great question i've never been military
you know when i there were some kids in
our school that was in rotc
and they were you know some of them
honestly were
inbreeding or doing inbreeding and they
were
[Music]
they used to run around after school
with wooden guns and pretend
people was attacking the damn philosophy
center or whatever you know
uh you know they'd be defending the
library you'd see six of them out there
you know one of them knocked up out
there with a wooden gun and they're all
defending the damn
book drop off at the damn night drop off
at the damn library just
you know i respect them i'm not saying i
don't respect them but they were
the training bus was bleak you know i
remember that the training bus was
bleaking
um man what was i talking about
uh
oh well you know that's a great question
matt and i think that is a good question
to to
to put out to people you know i'm sure
we have a lot of listeners that are
military and thank you very much for
for your service you know i'm sorry a
lot of these uh these days the media
probably doesn't support you as much as
you
feel like it should you know military
does so much to keep us safe
um do you know that in america there's
always like we're only eight hours away
from uh we could be wheels up you could
have a
uh uh seal team six or uh
um you know one of those airborne groups
or
uh you know uh
or army ranger this i don't know exactly
what i'm talking about so
i'm gonna shut up but they're we're
always only
eight hours away from having just full
bore and that's crazy
you know what i'm saying you couldn't it
takes a family of four
damn four days to plan a [ __ ] to pack
a van to go to destin
so when you're thinking about or pack a
van to go to the damn lake of the ozarks
which is in missouri
and i didn't know it for years and also
did you know this
the s what is it called it's in
pennsylvania
the poconos is in pennsylvania
had no idea man for years i had no idea
i thought it was islands i thought i was
off of aruba or somewhere
but the poconos is in damn pennsylvania
so a lot of stuff being learned by
everybody but um
but yeah if you have suggestions what's
a good suggestion for somebody if
they're getting out of the military what
do you think
you know what do you think somebody's
getting out of the military if you've
been in the military hit the hotline
985-664-9503 and we'll put together some
uh
some ideas for you matt and just kind of
survey the crowd there
what else yeah man that's pretty
fascinating that we have that
capability to keep us safe you know
we've gotten so used to being safe here
in america in a way it's almost like the
people you have to be safe from now
is are in america that's the crazy part
like it's companies and it's you know uh
big tech and just things that can limit
your ability to be free
it's wild man just it's just interesting
to see once you don't have the enemies
outside or they're
you know because our previous
generations had that they were fighting
for territory and for
our borders and to secure
a place and then once you don't have
once that scare isn't there for a while
damn
the enemies is in the damn wi-fi man
it's crisis
i mean also i don't know what i'm
talking about um
let's hear something here man we got
some uh other nice calls that came in
some really good ones in uh
and let's ask let's let's uh let's hit
this one right here
what's up d.o it's luke um out of
birmingham
alabama luke got a b ham baby
and they call it b ham and i went to a
concert over there near pelham
alabama one time and i was a child man i
was a damn middle-aged child and
we was bent out on ecstasy or something
i don't know i ate something out of some
somebody's hand i remember [ __ ]
eating it right out of their hand
i didn't know what it was and and i ate
it and i was drugged out and i smoked me
half a pack of uh
newports in a row outside of a days inn
which was a semi-decent and it was fine
during the day that you know what they
advertise well
during the day it's fine
dude come about 6 15 pm
bro it's for days only dog it got
real dicey out there i'm upstairs
dude i was upstairs baby i wasn't out on
the streets around there
shout out days in baby d.i gang
sorry let's hear more luke this is about
you man
and so i i just got got my first number
from a girl
let's go that's what i'm talking about
that's what we do here
let's get some wins on the board baby
let's go lukey
or the first time i asked the girl uh
before i'm upstairs
your number and sorry i interrupted you
let's go back
the girl uh for her number sorry uh
oh i i just got got my first number from
a girl
and or the first time i asked the girl
uh for her number
and you know i was just going to get a
smoothie on my lunch break because
that's what i do when i get stressed out
oh yeah that's how i ended up on dmt
over there in maui
onward it's in the park but anyways
um i don't do
i mean she was [ __ ] beautiful man
and i'm gonna stop you right there looky
looky looky
looky here papa numeros
man there's not there's nothing we need
that first moment i don't know if it's
like this for women
a lady please if you're a lady bruh if
you running that little wallet bruh and
you're doing that for god and all of
that
and you can have children hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
and let me know if it's like this for
women because a guy when you see the
girl
when you see that little dime roll out
the bank baby or roll out the
starbuck you know or the damn dw
shoes or whatever the little you know
the long johns
uh not the pant shop the long johns
fish store long john's uh silver
is he jewish is long john silver jewish
i don't know man but
um but yeah when you see whenever it
went out
that first glimpse just like damn
damn bro
it's like that kind of that stick you
know that's crisp
sting that comes from listerine
it's kind of like that bro better but in
your
in you like in your damn vulva or
whatever in you
like in your liking
like uh
you know when you because your penis
starts at your brain
you know that right your penis it's
that's where it starts it's all
activated out of the brain
so anyway yeah man there's nothing like
that first moment man
there's nothing like that first moment
bro
let's hear more and um
bruh she uh she texted me and i don't
know where do i go from here
i just got out of relation a bad
relationship bad breakup
uh it's been a year now i'm just getting
over here
i don't know where to start man i know
you got your girl troubles too
and even though you a sexy looking
[ __ ]
um just give me some advice on what i
should do with that number or how i
should uh
go about it i probably already [ __ ] it
up yeah
that's true i'm sure you have uh if you
like any dude i know
they texted too early bro onward
but uh um yeah man
i went to my first aaa meeting last
night too um
i was drunk but i looked that up and
that's uh
acceptable aaa meeting so i turned my
ass around because it felt my heart
but it went good um all right i'll let
you go brother gang gang
gang baby man i'm proud of you for just
being brave man for just doing [ __ ]
you know for just staying busy man
you're staying busy you're staying
in the flow of life
you know what i start to realize and
this has happened for me recently i
start to isolate
oh i need to let you know i need to keep
myself from this and keep myself from
this and
how can i stay out of this deal this
situ you know i don't want to be i don't
know i don't
and the more i do that the more i
isolate and the more i get
alone and feeling alone
and for me that's a lot of my alcoholism
a lot of whatever the ism is inside of
me whatever the thing
whatever that dirty baby that crawls
inside of me that's what it's bait
a lot of it is that it's just that thing
that wants to keep me
separate keep me alone
keep me in that womb you know wherever
that womb is
you know i want to be on that i want to
be that cat in the top box while
everybody else is getting dosed out in
[ __ ] martha
i want to be that cat in the top box
but that doesn't suit me though because
then i'm alone it just it's a trickery
and it's a trickery man and that's def
that's devil that's devil working
and that is devil working brother praise
god man
but i'm happy for you man let's get some
wins on the board if you had a win
hit us up the hot line 985 664 9503 let
me know your wins
we need some wins in the books
yeah let me know your wins if you tried
something something happened you know
and congrats on the meeting man it
doesn't matter
there's no right way to do anything
there's just your life there's just your
path
and uh yeah it's look it's neat to check
out
you know i've been in them before um i
don't know if i've ever been in one
drunk before
but i've been in one the night after
drinking many of times man um
and it doesn't matter man uh
but good for you just staying in the
flow of things as much as i don't want
to sometimes
everything inside of me says no i don't
go say you can't
but then when i go then i'm in i realize
that i'm okay
and that's one thing this whole a lot of
society right now there's this thing of
this separation how can we close
everybody off and just make them
it feels like anyway and this is just to
me i'm not saying this to everybody
but it feels like there's a lot of
society
trying to just close us off to be alone
which then creates suffering
so then we can buy something to make us
feel better
and then they want you in that little
rose box coffin baby
five feet by 18 inches daddy they want
you playing small ball
but lucky is out here
smoothied out boo boo i'm upstairs
[Applause]
looky's out here smoothied up
cause he's dealing with some dub ass
[ __ ] work stress
and he's logging digits at the park baby
that's what we do
play ball
[Music]
i don't care if you're in the game i
don't care if he's the third bait coach
i don't care if he's a streaker
get in the field
and there's that skill so you hear that
and apparently when i get too fired up
that thing goes off thank you luke thank
you for that call man uh
man i made you made my day you made my
day man
you know and that's all you can make at
the days in bro because 6
15 comes around pop pop
veldrin's out there freaking so the dude
there'll be somebody out there
cooking them cooking a can of beans with
a [ __ ] uh
15 cow baby somebody's losing it
keeps you got to keep your hair people
losing their hair they shouldn't be
you know more than 50 million men in the
u.s suffer from male pattern baldness
sounds like it's god's plan but
you can fight it there are only two fda
approved medications that can prevent
hair
loss keeps offers both
yeah keeps offers a simple stress-free
way to keep your hair that's it
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months so you have to leave your
home
you know you can get it at home because
it can be it can be embarrassing dealing
with the hair stuff
you know i've been there i went and got
the rogaine and you carton this [ __ ]
around you put it in a different little
thermos so it doesn't look like
rogaine so people don't know what it is
if they see it
and then you accidentally [ __ ] you
think it's lemonade one time you know
you just a lot of poor choices and [ __ ]
but whatever
but it's low cost treatments start at
ten dollars per month and keeps offers
generic
versions as well discrete packaging
proven results
prevention is the key and that is true
treatment can take four to six months to
see results so act
fast if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss
go to keeps keps dot com
theo to receive your first month of
treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
t-h-e-o to get your first month free
keeps.com theo
support the podcast support the podcast
uh and lastly i want to say that uh
super
specio is kratom kratom getsuperleaf.com
theo promo code theo
speciosa
it can have you feeling good feeling
elevated
i'm talking kratom baby that good good
you see there's all different types of
kratom depending on the strain and
serving size
it can either help you relax or give you
energy
it is a plant that's from nature it can
be a chill buzz
with a little pain relief sprinkled in
or bam just like at another scoop
you got that vitality and you could
teach somebody how to dougie right there
in your front yard
right now if you use promo code th eo at
checkout
superspeciosa super specio
will even give you 20 off kratom is an
all natural
herbal supplement that's like a bullet
train to enlightenment
check it out try it out
if you want to check with your doctor
first maybe you should if you need to
check with a sponsor first maybe you
should
but give kratom a try if you feel you
should if you don't like it
superspeciosa will even give you your
money back
there you go that's easy go to
getsuperleaf.com
t-h-e-o promo code theo for 20
off that's get super leaf dot com slash
theo promo code theo for 20
off also i want to let you know we have
the podcast ville
2019 art that was done by papio tune
it's now available you can get it
it can be framed or unframed it can be
on a mug
it can be i mean it's really really
beautiful
i want to get one here in studio and uh
and you can check them out that's right
podcastville mugs and digital prints are
available now
yep just go to theovon.pixels.com
and it has all your favorite podcasters
on it you can check it out
um man
i'm excited to hit up these single miles
we got mother's day coming up
you know my mom came in town uh
you know i was definitely excited you
know i i saved some things at home
for us to do together like just to go
shopping for small
things and not even save them i think i
just hadn't done them
so you know it was nice uh to spend time
together i thought about having her as a
guest on the podcast but
we don't really have it set up right now
to do two people uh so we're gonna have
to wait uh maybe another time
um you know there were sometimes it was
a little stressful and we kind of just
went to our
mutual corners and uh and that was okay
you know
um you know it was kind of nice in a lot
of ways man it was
nice just like i think i kind of come to
some realizations that like
you know my relationship with my mother
doesn't it doesn't have to be some
perfect
thing you know i think always in my head
that it needs to land in some perfect
place or it all has to be figured out
um and it's okay
it can kind of be that's that skill saw
it can kind of be um
you know it can just be kind of fluid
and uh and so there was nice
there was some niceness about that you
know there was some niceness just to
have
some times also i was like you know i
just need some space to myself
and i'm an adult now so i could do that
i could take that space
where when i was a child i didn't really
have that ability if i needed
know if you know you're you're kind of
in your parents you know you're in their
domain so um
so it was good man we went picked out
some different stuff and got some
different thing got some soap got a
shower caddy in my shower
because everything was just sitting on
the bottom you know when you're kind of
like you know just two-stepping around
the toothpaste and all of that
and just trying to kick stuff away from
the drain
if you've ever done that in your shower
you just like don't set anything up so
it's just in the bottom you just keep
kicking it away from the drain but
um got a shower caddy forgot silverware
so still doing uh you know still washing
the plastics off in the sink but
um but it was nice we didn't have really
like any heart-to-heart combos or
anything like that
you know and that's okay um
i'm glad that we both made the time to
spend time together though
you know we both made a commitment to to
spend time together
and um
[Music]
and it was nice man we went out one
night mom had a margarita her second one
she's ever had
so that was cool so i had to put i had
to ask her some you know
ask her some questions about that about
her first marriage after that and so
you know i got into that a little but um
yeah we had a nice time man i know that
she loves me and
uh you know and i'm hard to love
sometimes you know
i'm particular as an adult
and i think they were those were safety
mechanisms that i used as a kid
uh and now they sometimes keep me too
safe
in some ways you know they can sometimes
keep me so
safe that uh i'm separate
um but that's okay i'm not complaining
people sometimes are like man you're
whining i'm not having self-pity i'm
just
sometimes i like to share what i'm
thinking or feeling
and it's not complaining it's not i'm
just sharing it
you know i just i i just i'm just
sharing it
and so that's okay you know it's
mother's day coming up and um
we're gonna get to that in just a second
and uh and first i want to get into
maybe one or two
more oh this happened bro a couple
italians
threw a flat screen off a damn uh thing
yo we're on the 47th the floor here
oh my god and i don't know if you can
see this literally
it's two two white dudes one of them in
a straight up jita jersey
okay so uh
italian could be jewish this kid but it
looks italian
um but definitely has a television
obviously it's either
it's probably from the hotel 42nd floor
these two dudes are yacked up baby
on some of that italian yak baby that
giddy up bro
that freaking brain father dog you know
what i'm talking about baby
that freaking genealogy dust baby you
snort your way back to your grandfather
on some of that strong [ __ ] baby gang
um and they just threw a television off
the 42nd floor
in what looks like i'm gonna say this is
las vegas
[Music]
it's pretty funny
i love how as soon as it hits the guy
runs into the hotel room
like at that like at that point
oh man that [ __ ] is good dude oh that
was good
so right there that's full italian man
and that is
uh i mean it's just you know what makes
me mad
the quality of product
and that's product quality they call it
but that makes me mad man a long time
ago dude television you threw that [ __ ]
off you needed two people to throw that
[ __ ]
okay and when that thing hit dude
i mean timothy mcveigh probably you know
his spine got a little straighter
you know that thing really those things
it was
glass on the front and it was a damn
there was a bulb in there and there was
some real weight and girth to it that
thing
that thing would get to the 42 floors in
five seconds this thing took five
eight seconds it should that thing
landed like a damn dove down there
that thing landed like a dove baby damn
so we need to just heavy these [ __ ]
up man
but that's a ballsy move man
throwing that thing 42 floors throwing a
tv off man
praise god that's italian daddy let's go
got another video right here of a giants
fan
reacting to the eagles stealing their
player
are you kidding me are you smoke get the
[ __ ] upstairs now
get the [ __ ] upstairs now
are you kidding me you [ __ ] put a
hole in the board
and the guy punched two holes into the
wall the guy couldn't handle the pick
the draft picked the giants the eagles
stole the draft pick
and the guy put two holes into the wall
here's what i'm saying ladies you want
the holes in the wall
you want the holes in the wife
sometimes you got the exertion has to
get out
so i think that this man did the right
thing
i think his wife also did the right
thing by telling him
to get the [ __ ] out if suddenly he
thinks he's a damn general contractor
when he's hopped up on [ __ ] heineken
summer rail
at 4 p.m in the afternoon
to be a damn giants fan come on bro
y'all got evan ingram y'all should have
him throw and catch the ball dude
but look man that's the kind of stuff
that's going on out there in god's world
man and so that's what happens when you
watch the nfl draft
dude go to flag football watch flag
football
it's better some of it's co-ed there's
hot chicks bro
live it up hey man man
man we've had a good time so far um
i've had a good time anyway thank you
guys for being here
um and speaking of sports man this one
last sport i want to check in on uh
and this is underwater sport right here
[Music]
if you've seen this if you can see the
video on youtube that the man
is man underwater and i'm not going to
say this is a
you know this is definitely a
all male type of sport this is
definitely a lot of men that's
homeowners
if you know what i'm talking about
brother you know what i'm saying full
men on men
this tickling each other underwater
trying to get a little
look like a damn little sausage from
each other like a little
sausage bun one of those eight answers
and then they
oh that big boy is pushing him
oh god he threw that
oh and who was that that man's wearing a
thong
but this is definitely this is the kind
of [ __ ] that would go on at a rest area
if they had
pools so you could just say really
obviously that's what this
is and i hope these men are all safe and
this could be a prison thing also
because it seems real touch and go
uh all right let's get on um
thank you for whoever sent that in thank
you for everybody who made calls into
the uh
episode today all right with mother's
day uh
coming up um you know it's an exciting
time for us to do something
uh for some single moms out there and i
want to thank everybody who's a part of
our patreon
and just a listener of this podcast um
you know i always feel everybody's
support in this
realm and um and so
you know it's nice for me to just be the
liaison of us offering a little bit of
assistance here and there
and just a moment to uh
recognize so we got a submission that
came in today
uh let me play this video right here
yo what's up theo's chico from berkeley
california
out here doing some urban farming a
little chicken back there
dang chico got that freaking yard bird
son
that bait that freaking backyard dinner
section daddy let's go
uh thank you for calling chico let's
hear more
back there i wanted to nominate my
homegirl alicia
for the um the single mother's thing she
had her son while she was in high school
a young mom and put herself through um
through community college
put herself through her bachelor's
program in nursing all while holding a
job
now she's actually in a master's program
for nursing at the university of san
francisco
paying for that herself and all you know
she's got she's got a new job while
she's doing that so
girl's been working hard taking care of
her son she cooks meals for him every
night
they always sit down for dinner and you
know take them out on bike rides every
day
she's working really hard and she
deserves everything she can get i'm
really proud of her
love to see what she's doing um
appreciate what you guys do over there
this past weekend peace gang baby thanks
man that's a nice message man that's
nice you that you uh recognize those
things and see those things and
oh just care to share them with us man
so thank you for doing that
uh chico yeah let's hit up this young
lady right here alicia
elisha now that's a name right there
alicia
sound like a um piece of ice
hey alicia can you hear me yes
are you mad at me i don't know what this
is well i'm not a bad guy i mean i'm not
a great guy i'm
semi-decent i think
but uh i just work on a podcast so
that's what i do
and i was raised by a single mom and so
sometimes on our podcast we have
listeners that call in and nominate
single moms for us to do something nice
for
so you have a friend named chico is his
name
and he seemed like a real decent man and
uh
anyway he called in and nominated you
and uh
so we just wanted to send you 750 to do
something nice for
uh your kiddo one day so that's
really all this is really is this real
yeah unfortunately yeah i know we're
bothering you today and i am sorry about
that
but yeah he really did he just called
and left a a message and just said hey i
know this girl
and she is a hard worker and she spends
a lot of nice time
with her son and makes him meals and
they go on bike rides and
you know i just really admire her and so
i wanted to nominate her
and so now we're just doing our part of
the responsibilities just to call you
and let you know
so you know chico or not i do
and tell me about him be honest about it
oh my gosh this is so awkward
yeah life's kind of awkward you know
he's a cool guy
is he sweet he's a good dad too
oh nice yeah i don't think he's doing it
to be weird or anything i think he just
i think he just thought it would be a
nice gesture you know
yeah with your kiddo like you got a
little son huh
yeah i have a son what's he like pretty
he is
oh yeah he's very polite oh that's
nice that's my favorite thing is when
somebody says nice polite
polite things you know yeah
is it fun raising him yeah
it's like i learn about myself while i'm
raising him too
and we pretty much have been growing
together
oh that's pretty cool yeah i think i got
to get me a child one of these days i'm
about ready to hatch something you know
what i'm saying
sure okay um
well that's it so i'll just have uh we
have a producer from our podcast who
will just reach out and then we'll just
you know uh just send you just a little
gift and then you can
just be something fun you can do what
you know summertime's kind of coming
maybe
uh you guys could go do something fun
together if you want
sounds good thank you okay you're very
welcome and thank chico and i hope you
have a nice day
thank you you too okay bye bye
bye and maybe people skeptical you know
some people is skeptical
and that's okay maybe she's not
skeptical [ __ ] i
she don't know me you know what i'm
saying if i saw some man called from a
damn mortuary
you've seen this place and dressed in a
damn waymatic shirt what is it you know
you know and wearing these pants
then i would definitely be skeptical as
well but that's okay that's a good mom
being skeptical
that's a good mom you know skeptical
first that's my motto baby you know that
so let's try we got one more uh
nomination that came in let's check that
out right now
hey theo my name is jeremy i heard about
what you're doing with the single
mothers
much respect to you i think that's a
beautiful thing i was raised by a single
mother myself
and any chance we can to highlight
single mothers and how strong they
really are
i'm on board i'd like to nominate
desiree
i've known her since she was a young
girl i've watched her grown from a young
woman to a grown woman to a mother
and watching her raise her children or
her child
after the loss of the father of the
child it's just a beautiful thing
and um if i can do anything to help her
i would
well thank you brother i appreciate you
putting her on our radar and uh
let's see if we can't give her a buzz
right now actually
hey desiree hello
where you at you at school still huh
where you at man it's hot
yeah it's hot everywhere it is it is
what the kids doing ah they just went
back to class i have to
i don't get off until two i have like
like 15 minutes
you got 15 minutes yes oh we only need a
couple minutes girl
you know what i'm saying that's the kind
of guy i am you know what i'm saying
so i work on a podcast my name is theo
and i work on a podcast and we um
we have a section of our podcast where
our listeners will nominate single moms
and we'll reach out to them and they
they'll just send in a video and a man
named jeremy sending a video
saying some really nice things about you
and how proud he is
uh to know you and that you're a single
mother
and so um we just wanted to reach out
and
and offer you just a gift because i was
raised by a single mom so we just want
to send you 750 bucks to go do something
nice with the kiddo this summer
what oh my god
so that's it that's it if you still got
the kiddo you still a single mom or not
yeah yeah you know you can't live
without them and you can't live with it
yes my son is seven and he's in first
grade
oh that's beautiful does he go to your
school or no
yeah he's here at my school because it's
convenient so we get off at the same
time
and we go home do homework and spend
time today he has a baseball game so
we're gonna head to his baseball game
after this
oh nice what position is he playing yet
um he does pitcher and uh he loves first
base and he's a catcher right now
oh yeah that's something well they got
him in some good positions they used to
put me out in the field out there eating
grass with them kids
right twirling around and stuff oh they
used to put me out there one kid got
lost out there i don't know where he's
at
um yeah it was a different time back
then
um so you're kidding he's seven years
old
yeah seven years old yes oh that's nice
what does he like to do so he likes to
play baseball he must be pretty active
huh
keep him active he likes to play
baseball basketball
oh wow dang and where do you teach that
you're a teacher
yeah i'm a teacher listen i'm in school
i'm a teacher so i'm a full-time teacher
and i do school part-time and then you
know mother full-time and
all that all types of hats dang you got
all the hats on huh
yes well well jeremy thinks the world of
you and we do too and we just wanted to
let you know that you know that uh
that even though sometimes probably
being a single mom might not seem like
people are thinking of you
we just wanted to let you know that
people are thinking of you
man let's bring me thomas bringing me
the tears no thank you this this is
really
this means a lot so thank you so much
thank you
oh you're welcome you're welcome we just
want to let you know we out there
grinding with you you doing all the work
but we got your back that's all we say
you know hey you know and that's that's
right thank you guys so much and it's
who's cheering
back like you just said so thank you so
much well we certainly are and happy
early mother's day to you and you guys
have uh fun at the baseball game and um
i'll have my producer reach out and uh
and you guys go do something fun this
summer
okay no thank you so much theo thank you
and nice meeting you
yeah nice to meet you too it's a
pleasure you look lovely today and i
hope you have a
good uh a good rest of the day okay
thank you sweetheart
bye bye bye man and that's beautiful to
see you know it's nice to see
uh just a smiling face
you know it's nice to see a mom smiling
you know that makes me feel good
you know i don't think you know my
mother was under a lot of stress
growing up and and i just nice to see a
mom just
having some joy you know and that's what
this is all about man it's just those
moments of connection
you know and that's really what life is
about i think
as much as i want to isolate sometimes
and i want to get in my own space and i
want
and i think that that's the answer
you know i think if i can just
get this other little rest or this other
little separation or this other time to
myself then i'll be
but it's it the thing that i it's a
trick
and this connection that we need
you know the opportunity even just the
opportunity to listen for 30 seconds for
a minute
about a mom who likes going to play see
her son play
pitcher first base catcher all some of
the skill positions when i was out there
and damn
left field and people was eating
mushrooms eating psychedelic mushrooms
on accident out there
praise god but
but yeah there's just something warm
about it man
there's something
there's something
almost relieving about it
there's something almost relieving about
just listening to uh having a
conversation with a
connecting with a with a with a with a
young lady
and hearing her just talk about how she
cares about her son and just how they
have a nice little time together
you know um
for both those ladies you know i thought
it was really sweet alicia said her son
is polite
that's a man that's a nicest a little
polite kid man that's the nicest little
thing you know
because then man it just offers so many
other bridges to be built there when you
already have politeness out of the gate
so much opportunity for connection man
when one person is saying hey
um what else man that's all i got
you know that's all i got happy early
mother's day to you guys
uh and father's day i know there's a lot
of single dads out there too that are
grinding and getting it done
and look we'll switch it over to you
guys one of these days
and run it up for the pops out there uh
but uh i'm excited to see some of y'all
on tour
and i'm just excited i'm just excited to
be a part of this podcast man
you know i'm staying busy and i'm
working just i'm just not giving up i'm
not giving up on myself
you know another week i'm not giving up
on myself
and i might give up in certain moments i
might not win every moment but
i'm gonna do my best to win the day if i
can and i if i don't win every day i'm
gonna do my best to win the week you
know
uh and you can too you know and i know
that uh most of you are
and for those who aren't who are
struggling man uh
you know just hang in there
that's all you get you just gotta hang
in there that's the
thing you know life is a dog man but
it's every part of a dog
you know and some parts will scratch it
some parts will bite you but some parts
is warm
some parts wag
hell some parts you get a little bit of
milk out of them you know what i'm
saying bro that's a different i mean
that's
only certain times but whatever you know
what i'm saying praise god baby
you guys be good to yourself man you
guys deserve it and on the way out today
we're going to listen to
uh josh kelly hold me my
lord and man this is josh kelly
featuring
all voices in this one man it really
really
now it really does it for me you guys be
good baby gang
sing down the sun
here we go baby shine down your song
so that it might
breaking news tonight millions of
americans ordered a shelter in places
there's turmoil at the cdc controversy
at the home the darkest of days
come on josh kelly's
holy holy holy lord holding my heart
down on my knees asking you to hold me
[Music]
is
people in the country
until i found
[Music]
to make way for a brand new star
yes he did
[Music]
holy holy holy lord holding my heart
down
call me my
[Music]
go
[Applause]
please holy holy lord holding my heart
come on josh kelly
i'm down on my knees asking you to hold
me
hold me hold me with your loving
is
[Music]
man he knows how to put it on the grill
he sure does
you know he sure does know how to put it
on the grill that's josh kelly hold me
my lord
featuring all voices again